[Music]
now once more i find myself on the
defensive side of the ball in this
cancellation though as always the
objective is to make a play get the
turnover put the offense on defense
that's why i'm playing in the dime right
now six dbs on the field free safety
back deep ready to grab the pick kind of
losing track of the point i was trying
to make with this analogy
anyway the point is this weekend i was
again the subject of outrage and this is
embarrassing for me as someone who's
normally quite meek and gentle and
non-confrontational prefers to shrink
away from the spotlight i also consider
myself to be a people pleaser and i have
other deluded ideas about my own
personality but we won't continue down
that path right now what upset the
internet this time is a discussion that
began on this podcast on friday i read a
comment from a listener during the
reading the comments segment of the show
where he asked whether his fiancee's
refusal to take his name upon marriage
should be considered a red flag
and i said that not only is it a red
flag but it's a deal breaker as a man i
would not marry a woman who didn't want
to share my name i would recommend that
other men draw the same line
now i repeated this point on twitter
later that afternoon everything that
followed is therefore really the fault
of the listener who brought this subject
up i hope you're happy sir look at what
you've done
this is on you so over the course of the
next three days a familiar chain of
events followed
thousands of people very upset that i
would suggest that women ought to take
their husband's name the fact that i
would call this issue a deal breaker was
all the more abhorrent to the outrage
masses they've let me know that i'm a
sexist a misogynist a bad husband a
tyrant a bigot a barbarian
one guy said that my opinion on the
subject is evidence
that i might be murderous and actually a
physical danger to my family
just because i want to share my name
with them
others went a different direction saying
that my my perspective proves that i'm a
sexually repressed virgin a fact that
will no doubt come as a great shock to
the mother of my four children
but rather than give a general overview
overview i think it'd be helpful in this
case
to read a few of these specific
responses
and this i think is a good
representative sample
i'm choosing only from the blue check
squad verified accounts media people
authors academics and so on so here are
a few of them here's what they were
saying uh bethany says
i really don't hold much importance to
my surname a random name my granddad
chose and a pub after moving to england
my mom has a different surname now too
but i definitely would keep my name just
to spite angry men steph says this is so
toxic women do not belong to men
therefore it isn't a requirement for us
to be branded with your surname it's a
woman's choice it's rare to hear of men
taking women's surnames so if you won't
do the same for us keep quiet lol rachel
says would consider it a deal breaker if
any boyfriend expected me to take his
name women have their own identities any
man who expects a woman to give hers up
for him without discussion clearly
doesn't fully grasp that heather says
damn how do i break it to my fiance that
after 11 years we're gonna have to end
things because i'm not planning to
change my name
is that something i do over text or
and amy says i'm amy alcon i've always
been amy alcon and even if i weren't an
author etc marriages may come and go i'm
me for a lifetime and my name reflects
that
of course the really funny thing about
all this and most of the rest of the
responses from feminists on the subject
is that they all seek to prove that
they're strong and independent women by
refusing to take their husbands names
and instead keeping their father's names
quite literally participating in the
patriarchy while pretending to dismantle
it
the other thing almost as funny
is that each response only underscores
rather than undermines the original
point i was trying to make
bethany says that she would refuse to
take her husband's name purely out of
spite
now fortunately for her this probably
won't ever come up
i mean she can she can actually force
her cats to take whatever name she wants
to give them but still she confesses to
being being driven by spite
steph and rachel see the unity of
sharing a name as branding
they would consider it a deal breaker in
the other direction if their future
husband dared to request that they have
a shared family name
heather says that she's getting married
to her boyfriend after 11 years
and doesn't plan to take his name 11
years
this is someone whose commitment issues
are probably terminal at this point
doubly so for amy alcon who says
again marriages may come and go
so you see in these answers
not just that cat ownership tends to
make women very bitter but also
evidence of two other things
one
that the trend to move away from sharing
the husband's name
is driven primarily by an ideologically
fueled hatred of our cultural traditions
and two
that it's a symptom of a society that
fears commitment
so let's talk about both of these in
reverse order
starting with two
marriage if it's anything worth doing
is the bonding of two people into one
marital unit
it is a union
it is a decision to share your life and
even in many ways to share your identity
with somebody else it's not that you
lose your identity when you get married
but rather that your identity has
changed and it's bonded to this other
person fulfilled by them and by the love
you share
if this all sounds like a bunch of uh
hocus-pocus to you
that's fine
but please don't ever get married i mean
why would you if you don't believe in
what i'm saying then you don't believe
in marriage and the worst thing you can
do when you don't believe in marriage is
get married
if you do believe in marriage
then the very first thing you should do
the very first thing you should want to
do is come together under the same name
is this a symbolic move yes but marriage
is symbolic it's real but it's also
symbolic
your name is real and also symbolic
you know what so we know what sharing a
name symbolizes it symbolizes unity
commitment togetherness a shared life
what then does not sharing a name
symbolize
you can't say it symbolizes nothing it's
gonna symbolize something
that the decision to keep your own name
is a symbolic gesture in its own right
what is it symbolizing it symbolizes
separation detachment disunion
names are important everyone recognizes
that at some level
the left recognizes it which is why they
make such a big deal out of demanding
that people respect the new name of a
trans person after they quote transition
to call somebody by their old name their
dead name as it's called is an egregious
offense why because names matter the
symbolism in a name is profound john
proctor in the crucible would rather be
marched to the gallows than sign his
name on a false confession he was
willing to give the false confession
he was willing to have the whole town
told that he gave it
but he couldn't sign his name on the
paper he chose death rather than that
why because it's his name it's it's the
name that his sons will carry down to
their children and through the ages
he couldn't stand a sullied
in our deluded yet materialistic and
utilitarian age we don't understand
things like dignity and symbolism we
pretend not to even understand why the
symbolism of a shared marital name is so
crucial
yet the people on that side admit to the
truth
when they say something like marriages
come and go they see marriage as
temporal and fleeting while names are
deep and rich and permanent
but marriage is supposed to be deep and
rich and permanent also which is why it
should be formed under a shared name
but then
why share the man's name and not the
woman's
well
a big part of the answer for me is that
i believe the man is supposed to be the
head of the family that may be
unfashionable to say but i you know i
care about fashionable opinions about as
much as i care about the outrage from
childless cat ladies but putting that
aside
here's another reason
because it's a significant and enduring
cultural tradition
as already established we live in a
utilitarian age
and also a stupid and shallow age
so we tend to look at tradition as
totally unimportant
superfluous or worse we think that it's
noble to break traditions just for the
sake of breaking them
we hate traditions we feel oppressed by
them because traditions come from our
ancestors and we think that our
ancestors should have no say in how we
live our lives even though we live in
the civilization they gave us
i reject that attitude
i despise it actually
i think that if you're gonna dismantle a
tradition
you better have a good reason and the
reason shouldn't be indifference or
spite
or half-baked notions of female
empowerment
you know gk chesterton said that you
know there are many fences in the world
that are worth tearing down but you damn
well better understand why the fence was
erected before you demolish it
tearing down fences on a whim
because they obstruct the path you
wanted to walk is foolish and arrogant
and a good way to get your face eaten by
a rottweiler
a similar thing can be said about our
cultural our cultural offenses our
traditions
which these days we dismantle with no
notion as to why no coherent reason
and the result is that we lose the
sturdy and beautiful things our
ancestors gave us and we replaced those
things with nothing at all
sharing the husband's name is among
other things a meaningful tradition
dating back centuries
there are those who want to discard this
tradition like they discarded so many
others which speaks not only to their
ignorance and their contempt for their
own history
and and the voice of their ancestors but
also for their disregard
it speaks to their disregard to for the
whole institution of marriage
that's why i said
what i said
and i stand by it
and why i say now to those who are upset
about it that you are once again
i'm terribly afraid to say
cancel well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content